auf geht es wird wieder
[Musik]
gestritten Mutter und Sohn aus dem
Westen der Republik Vater und Tochter
aus dem Osten jetzt treffen sie alle
aufeinander in Erft der zweite Filmen
sereitkultur
sichten
nazegriffe faschistische Begriffe
völkische Begriffe
die ich rede jetzt und unterich mich
nicht das kannst du dann machen Klartext
reden auf der Couch in einer Zeit in der
sich die Krisen stapeln und Deutschland
seine politische Balance verloren hat
zwei Familien zwei Generationen eine
Menge
Differenzen deswegen wird der Strom
extra noch mal von den grün
verknappt ihr zwei ihr seid so
sag mal gegensatzfilie da wird öfters
gestritten viel gestritten Haupt über
politische Themen gestritten also uns
Fam mir bisschen so eine 0815 Familie wo
sicherlich auch mal streit gibt aber
nicht so krasse
Gegensätze Streitthemen gibt es genug
rechts links ostwest vieles provoziert
die DDR war aber leider Pleite das muss
man auch sagen die war nicht Pleite die
war total pleite ja was ist denn der
Staat jetzt mit Billionen Schulden das
ist für mich so lange bleide der Start
ist für mich es funktioniert ja alles
noch noch
[Musik]
noch Christiane von Girke kommt aus
Berlin mit Z Stunden Verspätung in
Erfurt an Brandstiftung an den Gleisen
und ein Bekennerschreiben von links
ihren AFD Sohn sagt sie würde das gleich
auf die Palme bringen der wird da wier
sag ja wieder die linksradikal natürlich
gegen die wird wieder nichts gemacht nur
gegen uns die Rechten ja das kenne ich
ja schon familienzof so wie schon im
ersten Teil der Dokumentation
streitrepublik manchmal schreien wir
auch ne
ja Christiane ist die Mutter eine grüne
chr ist der Sohn und in der ch kan man
kaum weiter entfern sein derzeit in
Deutschland zwei Familien öffnen ein
Fenster zu ihren lebenswten Heiko ist
ein Protestwähler aus
Ostdeutschland warum wir kriegen
vorgeschrieben wel Heizung wir machen
wir kriegen vorgeschrieben wie wir im
Auto fahren ich sage ich sehe momentan
in der Politik das Gefühl wie Ende der
DDR dass die kleinen Leute auch
mehrgenommenen sind
Anreise kommen aus dem kleinen orttal in
Thüringen ich bin erstmal ganz ohne
Erwartung im Moment an die andere
Familie ich find es einfach spannend die
Leute kennenzulernen die wir ja jetzt im
Prinzip auch nur durchs Fernsehen kennen
schon allein mit einer
Parteizugehörigkeit lebt man in der
filterplase mal gucken was wir haben so
da sind wir schon an dem Problem nichts
davon wenn ich mir vorstelle dass sie
gar nicht wählen geht dann das finde ich
schon auch bedenklich eigentlich ne aber
würde ich sie auch gern Fragen na also
plus
grüne Christiane von Girke war eine
grüne der ersten Stunde saß mal im
Bundesvorstand der
Partei Servicetechniker Heiko Brauns
Kollegen haben ihn im Fernsehen
gesehen da muss ich sagen da habe ich
sehr viel Zustimmung bekommen sehr viel
Zustimmung weil die Stimmung ist halt im
bei mir an der Arbeit und bei den
Kollegen und Bekannten ist halt so dass
viele mit dieser Politik die aktuell
eine Regierung gemacht wird nicht
zufrieden sind und also keine Partei
mehr Vertrauen wirklich geschenkt wird
ja Hal ja tiefer tiefer ja wenn ich
nicht die AFD wählen würde als Protest
würde mich eher Richtung SPD tendenziell
sehen bin ja so Protestwähler vielleicht
stimmt er mich ja sogar um der AFD
Mann dass ich nicht als Protest mehr
wähle sondern richtig oder vielleicht
will ich da noch gar nicht mehr der
afdmann Chris schnapperz Sohn von
Christiane von Girke und
Parteifunktionär er ist
fraktionspressesprecher in
Nordrheinwestfalen die beiden kommen aus
dem wie man so sagt normalen Leben ja
und da ist einfach mal interessant zu
hören wie sind da die die Stimmung wie
sind die
Ansichten seit 89 kennt ihr uns drum
laden wiruch
kommt mal zu uns rüber spürt den
Sonnenschein ein ostwestgipfel zum 3
oktoberich mal kennen wunderbar
hallo Ich hasse dies J Westen Osten ja
also früher haben wir ja Ossi Wessi
gesagt bzw sagen ja die meisten immer
noch aber das finde ich auch übertrieben
inzwischen ich habe selber benutzt
ehrlich gesagt logischerweise auch viel
noch genutzt aber deutlich nach in der
Grenzregion da ist das sowieso viel mehr
verwaschen freie Platzwahl in erfurz
Industriedenkmal zentralheize du
möchtest ja ja ganz am Rand ganz am Rand
rechts au genau
rechts das war jetzt böse das war war
jetzt wirklich
böse rechts außen ist absolut rechts
außen ist rechts radikal ist reaktionär
ist also nicht rechtsradikal für mich
ist es rechts ist rechts Auen ganz
rechtsradikal und nicht zu akzeptieren
in der Gesellschaft die eigentlich
wirkliche Mitte dies mal gegeben hat in
der Politik in dieser Gesellschaft die
wird mittlerweile gar nicht mehr
akzeptiert stimmt das gar nicht mer
akzeptiert das genau die Mitte der
Gesellschaft die nicht dieses Land am
Leben hält wieder abgeholt wir von der
Politik das ist genau meine Intuition
dich bezeichne ich nicht als
rechtsradikal ich
bitte sonst würde ich ja nicht mit dir
hier sitzen ganz klar also nein da be
mir schon auch eine Linie ne das weißt
du
auch liebe Mama du warst ja bei den
68ern aktiv und hast die Grünen
mitgegründet aber du hast mich das
selbständige Denken gelehrt und bitte
wer der selbständig denkt ist heutzutage
ein linker oder noch schlimmer ein grüer
ich glaube heute wird jemand wie ich als
toxischer weißer Mann bezeichnen meine
beste Freundin kam nicht weil ihr Mann
gesagt hat ich setze mich nicht mit
einem afdler an den Tisch also für mich
war es sehr beeindruckend das zu sehen
dass du trotzdem zu deinem Sohn stehst
und hab da auch sehr viel Respekt davor
und habe aber irgendwann die Frage
gehabt dass du nicht manchmal gedacht
dass du ein falsches Kind mit Heim
gekriegt
hast meine langjährige Freundin die ja
nicht zu meinem Geburtstag gekommen ist
die hat nach der Sendung angerufen hat
gesagt Christian es tut mir alles so
leid ist ja völliger Quatsch also wir
haben uns jetzt wieder angenährt und
vertragen mit 14 habe ich noch docmens
getragen und er war er bisschen punkig
unterwegs da wollte ich mir noch die
Haare grün färben
wenn ich streng verboten hab ja das Ken
ich irgendwoher und auf jeden Fall
m war das eigentlich eine Entwicklung
weil ich merkte einfach zum einen was
mich störte dieses
antideutsche ja was im linken Kreisen
häufig ist ja du darfst nicht stolz sein
Deutscher zu sein und so wo ich immer
gedacht habe ja wieso eigentlich nicht
wieso darf ich das nicht sein also ich
meine wir können auf sehr sehr viele
stolz sein was Deutschland oder das
deutsche Volk oder das Vaterland
geleistet hat und dann dass die
Gesellschaft immer weiter irgendwie nach
links rückte und ich das
irgendwie das waren ungutes Gefühl
einfach ich bin glaube ich so ein
bisschen zwischen den Welten
aufgewachsen meine Mama ist sehr sehr
sehr weit im rechten Spektrum unterwegs
sagt das auch von sich selber ist da
auch ganz klar auch nach außen hin mein
Papa war früher tatsächlich ja PDS oder
linke also ich bin so ein bisschen
zwischen den Fronten auch aufgewachsen
aber bei uns war Politik gar nicht so
das große Thema zu Hause also ich selbst
kann mich halt weder mit dem einen noch
mit dem anderen identifizieren also mit
der mit dem rechten Flügel noch am
allerwenigsten tatsächlich schon wenn es
da dran hergeht ja wir müssen die
traditionelle Familie stärken
muttervaterkind da bin ich raus echt
okay da bin ich raus tatsächlich weil es
ist nicht das was sich für mich gut
anfühlt also aber es ist es ist ja die
Mehrheit also ich meine traditionelle
vatermutterkind ist sowohl für die
Kinder als auch eigentlich auch für die
Gesellschaft die Keimzelle des
Bürgertums die Familie das mag richtig
sein aber ich für mich habe auch
irgendwann beschlossen dass ich z.B
keine Kinder haben möchte und da sage
ich dann was ist aber dann mit uns
bleiben wir dann auf der Strecke obwohl
wir vielleicht eher dann sage ich mal
uns auf einer anderen Ebene engagieren
mit unserem Beruf mit unseren
Tätigkeiten
Halbtagsstelle Blechkuchen zur
Ausstellungseröffnung als Leiterin eines
Heimatmuseums janliert Rebecca mit
knappen Mitteln Rebecca braun sieht
nicht alles wie ihr Vater sie schenkt
gar keiner Partei mehr Vertrauen macht
ihren Stimmzettel
ungültig ich finde also nicht zu wählen
eigentlich in der Demokratie nicht gut
so als
verantwortungsvoller Bürger oder
Bürgerin würde ich ich denken sollte man
schon seine Meinung kund tun und ich
finde es auch ganz schlecht dieser große
nichtwähleranteil den wir haben ich gehe
schon zur Wahl tatsächlich
aber ich könnte mich jetzt keiner Partei
irgendwie zuordnen deswegen mache ich
mein Stimmzettel grundsätzlich mal
ungültig du bist ja jung ja und voller
Leben wie kommt das dass man so
politisch sich so nicht wiederfindet da
bin ich auch an mir selber
diese Generation in der ich groß
geworden bin also so nehme ich es
zumindest wahr wir sind sehr ziellos
generell und ich glaube das ist genauso
dieser Punkt dass man auch politisch da
so ins Schwimmen gekommen ist und wir
haben ja ein ganz anderen Fokus wir
müssen uns eher auf eine Stabilität im
Leben fokussieren wir können uns jetzt
nicht noch um Politik
kümmern also ich muss sagen ich habe ja
die DDR gar nicht erlebt nicht bewusst
ich bin zwar noch geboren in der DDR wir
sind meine Frau und ich sind gelernte
die derr
Bürger was gelernt ist wird nicht
einfach vergessen auch nach über drei
Jahrzehnten
nicht wurde alles verbönt nach der Wende
alles uns Entität wurde praktisch nicht
akzeptiert weil alles was wir gelernt
hatten bis dahin war ja plötzlich weg
wir mussten uns ja von jetzt auf gleich
ein anderen System anpassen und alles
was wir gelernt haben war nicht mehr
richtig so einfach war das schon nicht
ich fand es toll die Wiedervereinigung
aber für mich persönlich war es
natürlich sehr einschneidend weil wir ja
nach Berlin gehen mussten von Bonn nach
Berlin wegen des regierungsumzuges also
gerade als wir nach Berlin gezogen sind
muss ich schon sagen ich war 17
rausgerissen aus dem Freundeskreis und
so also ich würde mich da nicht als Fan
der wie man damals sagt Ossis bezeichnen
sondern war da eigentlich eher sehr
ablehnend und auch von oben herab wir
haben gewonnen das stimmt so ist es
auchübergekommen das glaub ich also das
stimmt aber es ist blöderweise hängen
geblieben dieser arrogante Blick auf die
Ostdeutschen Anfang der 90er Jahre
bewarb sich Heiko braun in Hessen
pendelt seitdem nach Eschwege wir waren
die ersten zwei ich einfach ostdeutschen
in dem bundesdeutschen Unternehmen
aufgrund unserer guten Ausbildung haben
s eigentlich schnell gemerkt dass wir
was auf haben ich weiß wie viel Jahren Z
war ein zwei Jahren ich weiß nicht mehr
genau hat mir ein älterer Arbeitskollege
gesagt also Eiko wisst ja dass ich was
gegen die Ostdeutschen habe aber ich
glaube wir haben die zwei besten
abbekommen also ich habe den Eindruck
dass du so in diese Richtung gehst da in
der DDR war eigentlich doch alles besser
das würde mich mal interessieren ich
habe ja gesagt ich bin gelernter DDR
Bürger ich bin in DDR groß geworden ich
habe die DDR anders erlebt wie sie nach
der Wende propagiert worden ist von den
Mädchen und überall da sind immer auch
wieder Einzel Beispiele rausgefunden der
ist verfolgt worden der war im Knast und
und und ich konnte mich nicht der frei
bewegen konntest du ins Ausland reisen
nein also das hat mich aber nicht
gestört den einen ander hat vielleicht
gestört das werfe ich unser ddrgegung
vor sie hätten die Leute reisen lassen
können ich konnte mich mit in der DD
halbwegs arrangieren mit dem System also
dich hat nicht gestört dass z.B die
Mauern tot und haben dich nicht gestört
nee sie hätten ganz normal Ausreise
beantragen können und es war es war
jedem bekannt dass der Schießbefehl an
der Grenze ist es wusste jeder ist ja
ein Unterschied ob ob man eine freie
Meinung hat also wie die freie Meinung
dass sie ausreisen wollten na gut ich
glaube wir versetteln uns was ich jetzt
über 30 Jahre nach den gemerkt habe auch
dieses System hat Ecken und Kanten ohne
Ende ohne Ende und die Leute sind auch
unzufrieden mit diesem System und
Demokratie ist für mich momentan nicht
mehr da du kannst wählen frei wählen ja
letztenendes ich mache jetzt mal ein
extrem be wenn die AFD irgendwann mal
49% kriegt werden sich alle anderen
zusammenschließen damit sie die 51%
kriegen da bin ich mir absolut sicher
und wenn sie die Rentnerpartei oder die
Kuen Band wen auch immer gibt dazu
nehmen diese
Demokratie mag nichts Neues die
Veränderung wollen die mögen es nicht
gerade die ehemaligen DDR Bürger sag ich
die AFD das ist eine neue Partei lass
mal machen ob s es besser ma ein anderes
AR ich
zeigen
Vergangenheit Tanken in
Eisenach wie immer Heiko und Ehefrau
Heike Brauns Alter Heimat fühlt man sich
schon eher in der DDR hier ja ja ja sch
schön viele Sachen der DDR waren einfach
besser der menschliche Zusammenhalt ganz
außer Frage und auch ich bin der Meinung
was Bildung
betrifft war besser organisiert ich habe
Maschinenbauer als richtigen Beruf
gelernt und parallel Abitur gemacht die
Ausbildung gibt's teilweise in neuen
Bundesländern gibt's die wieder
allerdings hauptsächlich schulisch und
das sind so viele saagen wo ich sage das
vermisse ich jetzt jetzt wird vieles
vieles vieles vieles vom Geld abhängig
gemacht na ja das waril die DDR war aber
leider Pleite das muss man auch die war
nicht Pleite die war total pleite was
ist denn der stat jetzt mit Billionen
Schulden das ist für mich so lange
bleide der Start ist schon für mich
schon lang am Ende aber es funktioniert
ja alles noch noch noch in der DDR ist
es ja so gewesen dass die
Wiedervereinigung im Prinzip auch aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen einfach
notwendig war wir haben es aufgedrückt
kriegt Kapitalismus Westen alles gut
alles friedev der Eierkuchen die im
Osten groß geworden sind das ist jetzt
die Generation die jetzt Richtung Rente
geht die vergleicht immer stärker das
ist dem Osten das im Westen und sie
haben in den 30 Jahren gefühlt für mich
auch
gemerkt ich kann zwar streiten aber es
passiert trotzdem nicht deswegen ist
momentan denke ich die Streitkultur im
Osten
aufmüpfiger wie im Westen 89 hat es
funktioniert die Leute sind auf die
Straße gegangen die haben das nicht mehr
auf der politischen Ebene ausgetragen
die sind auf die Straße gegangen da hat
die Masse einfach entschieden und ich
glaube diese Erfahrung wollen vielleicht
gerade die im Osten jetzt wieder in ins
Spiel bringen auf die Straße auf die
Straße auf die Straße
ich würde auch sagen was du vorhin
gesagt hast dass die der bezucht von
oben nach unten ist völlig verloren
gegangen also das werfe ich z.B auch den
Grünen absolut vor ja als bestes
Beispiel ist die Klimapolitik ja also
das ist wirklich verheerend ich bin
total dafür für diese Veränderung aber
wie das gelaufen ist und wie das
passiert ist und wie das erstritten
wurde ja das ist doch katastrophal
gewesen aktuell ist das Volk so es ist
eine schweigende Mehrheit für mich auch
da manche wählen a protest die AFD um
sich eine Stimme zu
[Musik]
verschaffen ganz viel angestaute
Wut Deutschland im
[Applaus]
Meinungskampf die demokratiezeit es gibt
Schreihälse aber wir können lauter reden
schönen Tag we dem Beispiel hab man es
gerade gesehen herr Scholz hat gesagt
wir sind stärker wir sind
lauter das heißt er will seinen Willen
mit aller Gewalt durchsetzen das vololk
wird nicht gehört das hat ih überhaupt
nicht interessiert da so kam das für
mich rüber und er ist der King er sagt
alles was er macht ist richtig ein Punkt
das macht nicht der die SPT das machen
alle Parteien mittlerweile viele
Parteien redet wir wollen wir wollen wir
wollen aber schaffen dann die
Voraussetzung nicht wirklich entwer
feht's am Geld oder es feht am Personal
es geht nur noch ums Geld in diesem
Gesellschaftssystem geht's nur ums Geld
alles muss im unterordnen ich bin
Arbeiterkind und ich habe auch die
Hoffnung dass die SPD das rer rum reisen
könnte für mich haben sie endgültig das
Vertrauen verloren die SPD wo sie damals
mit der CDU das erste Mal eine große
Koalition eingegangen sind war das
allererste was die SPD zusammen mit der
großen Koalition bestimmt hat war eine
diedenerhöhung das war für mich das Ende
da ich gesagt nicht mehr mit mir ich
muss da eigentlich Einspruch erheben
wegen der Diätenerhöhung die
Diätenerhöhung die werden ja gemacht
damit die Abgeordneten sollen nicht
bestechlich sein und ich finde dass z.B
die Bundeskanzlerin damals oder jetzt
der Bundeskanzler eigentlich viel zu
wenig verdienen die führen eine riesen
Firma zum Besten des Volkes ja das das
ist einfach zu wenig was mich an diesem
ganzen System momentan soeso stört
dieser das alles total auf das Geld
fixiert ist in der Wirtschaft ist es ja
nichts anderes die Geschäftsführer die
vorstellen oh wir müssen sparen
Deutschland ist arbeiten so teuer
Arbeitsplätze sind so teuer und selbst
machen sich die taschenvoll ohne Ende
und das ist in diesem System für mich
total daneben total daneben aber das ist
Kapitalismus das ist Kapitalismus pur
und du hörst nur Blabla und im Endeffekt
deswegen verstehe ich Heiko auch wenn
ich natürlich hoffe dass du uns
irgendwann auch aus Überzeugung nicht
aus Protest wählst wer spricht sich denn
gegen das Ganze aus wer ist denn
wirklich Opposition und wer ist für das
ganze nicht verantwortlich weil er nie
in Regierungsverantwortung war das sind
nur wir also ich finde das auch etwas
ungerecht zu sagen es passiert nichts ne
also das stimmt das
heizungsgesetz Chris jetzt ist mal gut
wirklich wir haben jetzt ganz andere
Probleme als früher ja wir haben den
Klimawandel der ja wirklich große
Probleme aufwirft wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die Energieversorgung besser
klappt das heißt Alternativen ener
deswegen deswegen werden die
Atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet in dieser
Phase deswegen wird der Strom extra noch
mal von den grün verkpp und man kauft ih
in Frankreich ein atomstom der wird der
Strom wird ja nicht verknappt es ist
genug Strom da inzwischen es ist absolut
Quatsch zu sagen wir müssen betteln bei
Nachbarn nein wir kaufen ih teuer ein du
musst dich davon lösen zu sagen
wir sondern Du musst die den EUR
europäischen strompol sehen und da
speist jeder ein und die preiswerteste
Energie wird gekauft so läuft das ja und
die preiswert ist Atomenergie nein das
ist nein Atomenergie war immer die
teuerste Energie entschuldige bitte da
bist du völlig falsch informiert ne mal
natürlich ist Sonne umsonst du willst
immer nur von Deutschland Mama kein
Industrieland der Welt geht den Weg den
wir gehen und das grüne
Wirtschaftswunder sieht so aus dass wir
als einziger G20 Staat unsere Wirtschaft
schrumpft werend alle anderen wachsen
das ist das grüne Wirtschaftswunder aber
die Energiewende ja man
muss für den Klima was machen bin ich
voll dafür wie es gemacht worden istich
hemdsärmlich Punkt es ist hemärmlich das
ist einfach so auf Biegen und Brechen da
alles durchzudrücken für mich und für
sicherlich viele andere Bürger ist die
AFD wirklich die einzige
Oppositionspartei in Deutschland
momentan die einzige Oppositionspartei
die an dem System was ändern kann und
selbst nur wenn sie die anderen dazu
bewegen
umzudenken gewählt wurde die AFD hier in
Sonneberg Thüringen gegen den CDU
Kandidaten und alle anderen gewinnt sie
ihr erstes Amt in Deutschland stellt den
Landrat nach der Wahl in Sonneberg hat
man es klipp und klar gesehen viele
politische Funktionäre haben plötzlich
ganz anders geredet ganz anders wie zwei
Wochen vorher interessant ist es ja dass
jetzt plötzlich alle Parteien auf den
Zug aufgesprungen sind also Migration
muss man jetzt doch begrenzen und ich
will es jetzt nicht wieder alles
aufzählen aber plötzlich sind ganz
bestimmte Themen also doch liegen wieder
da um diskutiert zu werden und diese
totale Abgrenzung die passiert die ist
glaube ich einfach falsch andere sagen
wieder gut wir müssen uns deshalb
abgrenzen wir müssen die aufd überhaupt
nicht zu Wort kommen lassen wir müssen
sie total totschweigen und irgendwann
wird sich das schon geben nein es gibt
sich nicht wir
sindest geburtstag der AFD juli in
Magdeburg westfische
fraktionspressesprecher
mendrin na ja wir haben den Anspruch
Volkspartei zu werden aber man muss
unterschiedliche Strömung abdecken an
der ehemaligen deutschdeutschen Grenze
vereinnahm Thüringens AFD Landeschef den
historischen Aufstand der ddrbürger vom
17 Juni
53 der westdeutsche Lehrer Björn höcke
biegt Geschichte wenn man weiß dass die
DDR Obrigkeit die Freiheitskämpfer des
17 Juni 1953 auch als Faschisten
markiert hat dann fühlt man sich mit
solchen Begriffen dann auch ganz
wohl das stinkt mir ich will den Mann
nicht sehen ja ich finde den Mann zum
Kotzen auf gut deutsch ja ich finde es
ist das ist kein Demokrat in meinen
Augen aber höcke ist der Inbegriff des
Bösen also ich habe höcke noch nie zum
Mord aufgerufen hören das habe ich auch
deutlich gesagt dass ich da teilweise
innerhallich definitiv auch andere
Meinung vertrete als er jetzt stellt
aber ein Teil der Partei da und ich habe
mich auch persönlich mit ihm unterhalten
ich habe da nichts festgestellt dass er
nicht demokratisch wäre warum kann eine
eigene Meinung nicht mehr wert sein als
du bist bei der AFD also musst du alles
irgendwie vertreten was AFD Programm ist
und was Höcker erzählt ich meine ich bin
Funktionär in dieser Partei ich arbeite
für diese Partei ich kann mich nicht
einfach hier freischnauze irgendwie also
das geht einfach das kann man von mir
auch nicht fordern das ist
unprofessionell sowas zu fordern ja und
wie gesagt er ist Parteimitglied Punkt
er ist ein erfolgreicher
Landesvorsitzender und ich weigere mich
auch immer dagegen immer zu distanziere
dich von diesem distanziere dich von
diesem eine Partei ist auch eine
Schicksalsgemeinschaft oderer gewissen
Art natürlich auch nicht falsch
verstehen Kampfverband Streit gutiert
der wha nicht trotzdem haben wir
Deutschen eine besondere Verantwortung
dem Faschismus auch gegenüber er benutzt
Begriffe in seinen Reden um die Leute
ein einzupeitschen da wird's mir
manchmal ganz schlecht wenn ich das höre
er benutzt wirklich naziegriffe
faschistische Begriffe völkische
Begriffe
die ich rede jetzt weiter und unterbrich
mich nicht das kannst du dann machen und
das ist finde ich für deutsche
problematisch also wir haben eine
bestimmte Vergangenheit du unsere
Familie ist selber auch verfolgt worden
also
väterlicherseits ich finde dass wenn das
sow weit ist dass du dann dich da
wirklich auch distanzieren musst nein
muss ich nicht ne also das das muss ich
nicht werde ich auch nicht solange AFD
Mitglied ist ist er afdmglied Punkt ich
habe dir gesagt wenn du jemals die
Meinung von höcke vertrittst dann bist
du für mich wirklich auch rechtsradikal
dann kann ich eigentlich unsere
Diskussionsebene nicht mehr
akzeptieren ich bini du bist wir sind
dabei uns zu
verlien